you hopeful that they could find a
resolution to this strike action with
the nurses oh I hope so I mean I have to
compliment that last young woman who was
speaking I mean what a lot of sense she
speaks and and so thoughtful and
compassionate and speaking not just on
her own sake not just talking for
herself but talking about the importance
of the National Health Service and how
they feel that they are fighting for the
National Health Service too how close or
far away do you think the government is
with all of the unions so we're looking
at the first of February national day of
action not calling it a general strike
but hundreds of thousands of people
going on strike that day it's such a
mess isn't it it's such a mess and I do
think it could have been avoided if the
government hadn't just left it until the
very last minute I think they were
posturing for such a long time saying
they were going to be hard and they
weren't going to talk and they weren't
prepared to negotiate and then now they
say they are but I do think that people
have got themselves dug into different
trenches now and it's really hard to get
out of it but we've seen the inflation
figures for December they are coming
down we heard from the Chancellor this
morning he was saying yes it's going in
the right direction but we're a long way
to go and we heard from the immigration
Minister somewhere you were in the last
hour and he said that um the last thing
that the economy needs right now is
spiraling inflation again because of pay
Rises okay I understand that
um and you know and it's good news
obviously that the inflation rate has
gone down but remember it's still the
third worst inflation figure for 30
years he I mean so so yes it's going
down but it's going down from a very
high peak and the amount obviously that
the government is offering is well below
the inflation rate to the various public
sector unions and so they are
effectively being asked to take a pay
cut yeah but there's a the government is
saying that if they were sat here they
would say we need to do that in order to
stop inflation going up again I
understand that I understand that but I
think we also need to be quite clear
about what it is therefore the
government is saying which is that if
they want to tackle inflation it has to
be on the back of cutting the the the
pay of public sector work because so
that's deflationary if they're getting
less money you know effectively I wonder
if we could just stay on money for a
second we'll ask you about this
disgraceful police officer who raped so
many women during his 18 years in the
Police Service
um the mayor of London labor mayor of
London has said that he will do
everything he possibly can to make sure
he doesn't get his pension we heard from
the government saying they don't think
he should get his pension what does
labor think
I personally think that the pension
shouldn't be relevant I mean it's not
for me to say it's obviously for a judge
to say but I would certainly expect him
not to be in a position to need to be
spending any money from any pension and
spending the rest of his life in jail
that's my view and what's your view on
the fact that he managed to get away
with this for such a long time
so I think there's lots of things about
this I think you know how did how was he
allowed to join the police why did his
colleagues allow him to continue to
behave and I'm not saying in the way
that he was obviously behaving at home
but there must have been Signs Now why
was nobody saying how concerned they
were about his behavior and how
how appropriate it was for him to be a
police officer I do think that we need
to have much much stronger vetting and
training and we need to have a culture
within the police where it's okay to say
I'm quite concerned about X's Behavior
did you see that WhatsApp message did
you hear the way that he spoke about so
and so and actually reporting it because
there are some really good people in the
Metropolitan Place and really dedicated
people and they are being completely
undermined by the behavior of these
of these appalling men who have been
allowed to be in the police force for so
long abusing women murdering women
raping women I mean no wonder confidence
in the metropolitan police is being
undermined we have a new leader of the
Metropolitan Police who's come back from
retirement from four years in order to
help clear it up and he turns up and yet
another case arises I really hope that
it is successful but what we think is
that there should be national standards
when it comes to vetting training you
know all of these things we think that
actually the Home Secretary should be
doing should be much more proactive than
she is and making sure this is not just
a map problem but making sure that she
recognizes that it's a problem in
relation to police forces up and down
the country and we need to make sure
that we have and we if we get into power
we will introduce national standards you
know throughout all the police forces we
will expect a certain standard when it
comes to vetting when it comes to
training and when it comes to chucking
people out you've got to Chuck people
out if they're inappropriate
where'd you stand on the gender Reform
Bill
so
I think again is another one of these
messes I think that if we had a
government that understood about
governing they would have been in
Consulting with the Scottish Parliament
it's not as though it's a great surprise
that the Scottish Pond was going to be
introducing this legislation I do think
the Scottish Parliament and the UK
Parliament should have been discussing
these matters for a very long time
before they did I think that it is
extraordinary that came about knock
arrived like the day before they passed
the legislation in order to discuss it
and I think what's happened is that the
the Scottish nationalists are now using
this as an opportunity to argue for you
know for nationalism and for separation
and for Independence and the and the
Tories seem to be using this as an
opportunity to spark off more culture
wars and and whilst they're fighting and
they've been squaring up to each other
for I don't know how long and now
they're off now they're fighting and
they're fighting on the backs of some of
the most vulnerable people in the United
Kingdom you know people who are trans
are more likely than anyone else to be
to be assaulted they have terrible you
know some people have such terrible
lives inside suffer such appalling
Prejudice and they're certainly not
reassuring women who are concerned about
safe spaces for women I mean none of
this seems to be part of the issue I was
there for part of the debate yesterday
and people just seem to be screaming at
each other there was much more heat than
light and it is a tragedy and we should
actually have the people who are really
affected by this legislation at the
Forefront of our minds when we decide
what the best thing to do is
should the bill be reformed so that the
age is more than 16 where do you stand
on well you know that labor Labor's
position is certainly that you know
legally people are hit a I mean it's
difficult because because people are
people and hard cutoffs always you don't
really fit people nevertheless we have
to invite but we have to do something so
so we tend to have a kind of
it's much more nuanced when you're 16
going 16 to 18 so there are certain
things you can do but like for example
if you join the military you can't use
weapons but you can join the Army at 16
or 17.
um you can marry but you have to marry
with the consent of your parents you
know so there's a kind of so I think you
know here at the weekend was expressing
his concern about a hard cut off being
at 16 where actually we think if there
needs to be a hard cut off then it's
probably more likely to be near 18 but
what we do need to do is we need to have
a proper consultation and it's certainly
right that the gender recognition act
which is a uk-based act before the Scots
introduced their own version is really
out of date and does need to be looked
at again we need a proper consultation
about it and some of them more inhumane
aspects of the gender recognition act
need to be looked at again okay it's
always great to see you thanks for
joining us appreciate it